So we get a lot of comments
saying, oh yeah, it's all well
and good, you identified the problem,
but how do we fix it? How do we fix it?
Understandable frustration
because things are bad, things are getting worse,
and I make that very clear.
But I guess people would suggest, like,
how does that help? Unless you have a solution.
So I wanted to do a video where we basically, sort of,
talk about that and talk about what the solution is.
whenever I hear people say, what are the solutions,
I always hear
in my head two separate questions.
So, I mean, the first thing is,
if you want a solution,
you do need to understand the problem.
And I have a very, very clear understanding of,
in my opinion, what the problem is,
which is that we have a growing wealth inequality.
If you want to make things better,
you have to bring that wealth inequality down.
If you want to stop things getting worse,
you at least have to stop it from increasing.
It's increasing at the moment very quickly.
This is what we talk about all the time,
it's up to people whether they agree with me on that.
Once you accept that, then how do you fix it?
And I always hear two questions there,
which is, number one,
technically, how do you reduce wealth inequality
or at least how do you stop it from increasing?
And number two,
how do you build the popular support for it?
I think these are basically,
these are the two battles which you have to win.
You have to win both.
There's no point winning one without the other.
You know, if you work out the taxes
but people don't support, you won't get the tax.
If you get people to support it but you then, you
then apply the tax badly, you’ll f*ck things up.
So you need to win both of those battles.
And I think
the first thing which I want people to understand is
we are not going to win this soon.
This is like number one thing
which you have to realise.
We are not going to...
at the moment wealth inequality
is increasing really quickly.
Living standards are falling quite quickly.
That will continue,
you know, I'd be very surprised
if we got any improvement on that
in at least a couple of years.
So, number one, like, sit with that for a bit
because that's something to deal with.
Like, that is something that you need to recognise.
Like, if you are hoping for better soon,
you're not going to get better soon.
And that is like a really depressing message to give.
But it's better to know that now
than to sit around hoping for improvement
that doesn't come.
So number one, except that, once you've accepted that,
then the next thing that you should accept after that,
is that if we want to,
if we want improvement, we
have to win the long term battle
because we're not going to win the short term battle.
We lost the short term battle.
We have to win the long term battle.
And that is why everything that I do
is focused on winning the long term battle.
Which is,
let me flip it
to a more positive way of looking at it,
which I think is true.
The opportunity here
to win the kind of
ideological theoretical debate
has never been bigger because
the percentage of people
in this country
and throughout the West
are being really hurt by the economic changes
now is bigger than it has been
for, since before the Second World
War, basically an enormous amount.
The current system is not working
for an enormous number of people
and that percentage of people is increasing.
Now, if you go back and you look at
the 2010, 2015 austerity period of the 2010s, basically
austerity decade in this country,
the pain was really loaded on like the bottom 20%.
And a lot of people will have felt a bit of pain.
But the pain was really loaded on the poorest.
And from the perspective of a democracy,
it's difficult to stop that
because the poorest are a minority
and it's hard for them to defend themselves.
Whereas now what you have is
50, 60, 70,
you know, pushing up to 80% of people getting hit.
That won't change.
That's going to keep happening.
So you have a massive opportunity here
to create this
broad political coalition of
people that are getting hurt.
So we have a massive opportunity
and not only that, it is definitely becoming
increasingly clear
to an increasingly large number of people
that the status quo is not working.
And there's really demand for an alternative.
And I don't think there are many
appealing alternatives being pushed.
And the ones that are being pushed,
I think are unlikely to work.
So the gap which we can fill has never been bigger.
There's a real big space
to bring a lot of people together to change the system,
which is increasingly
clearly not working for a large number of people.
But we're a long way from reaching them.
So
I think, I’m me, I’m one person.
And I think the biggest thing that I can do is to
grow this voice as
possible and I think, as big as possible.
But I think it needs to be really
clearly focused on
building this really clear narrative
that the reason things are getting worse
is because wealth inequality is getting worse.
And the only way to make things better
is to make wealth inequality better.
And the strength
that we will always have with that argument
is that it's correct,
which means that time will continually prove it
correct in the sense that,
you know,
Rishi Sunak and Jeremy Hunt are going to go on TV.
They're going to get voted out.
But, you know, Labour will come in
and they will say,
we're going to do the things,
I'm going to fix the economy,
we're going to make the economy better,
but they won't fix wealth inequality.
And I'll come out in this channel and I will say,
well, Labour will make all these promises,
but they're not going to make the economy better
because they're not victims of inequality.
And I will be right
and I will make a lot of clear predictions
about how that will manifest.
Rising house prices, decreased home
ownership, increased levels of debt,
decrease living conditions,
And I will be the one who is right.
My predictions will be right
and this will keep happening.
So I think the power that we have behind this voice
is that it's correct,
whereas the mainstream politicians will continually
sell tales of improvement, which won't happen.
We will be out saying, no, things will get worse.
You know,
you can go back and look at our videos from June 2020.
You know what I'm predicting
there's going to be an inflation
crisis, there’s going to be a cost of living
crisis, there's going to be like a massive
collapse in living standards in this country.
And that's all proved right.
You know, the longer we keep making this channel,
the longer we have this long
track record of
of being correct when everyone else is being wrong.
And I think that gives us this really
powerful opportunity to build a big message.
And I think there will be people out there
that would say, you know, well,
we don't
you know, we don't want to support your channel, Gary,
we don't want this to be like, you know,
you're not going to just be some saviour
that saves the world.
And I 100% agree with that message
because I don't want it to be just me, you know.
And it won't and we won't win if it's just me.
Like what I see myself as doing is
helping people to understand what's happening.
And then you go take the understanding
and you build your message.
This is the way like,
of course I'm trying to grow my message,
but we don't win by making this YouTube
channel have a million subs,
you know what I mean, it's no good.
We're not going to win.
It would be great if we had millions subs,
and I think we will get there one day, but
we won't win.
We will win
if my YouTube channel has a million subs
and f*cking his does, and his does, and his does,
and you know, not just on YouTube, you’re
spreading your message in whatever way you can,
you know what I mean, and that's like,
you know
if you can build a big voice for yourself great
but you don't need to
you know
if enough people spread this message
within their communities, that would be enough.
You know, their friends, their family,
the people they go to football with, their workmates.
You know, this...
I don't see this is as about being me...
I don't want this to be about me.
I want this to be about one clear, true idea,
which is you cannot make this better
unless you deal with this problem,
this problem of wealth inequality.
And, you know, I look at the way that,
you know, Nigel Farage
created a country where, you know, 60% of people
demanded Brexit and he f*cking got his Brexit.
You know,
for better or worse he got it, you know,
and you know that
as everybody is seeing
and I think people continue to see did not
and will not fix our economic problems,
we need to make this happen for wealth inequality.
We need to create a country where it becomes
common knowledge, just general common sense.
If you don't fix wealth inequality,
don't fix the problem.
And then then people like me
and hopefully other people who will adopt the message.
We can hold the politicians feet to the fire
and we can say, no, you know,
the people demand this thing
and they will not vote for you
unless you give them this thing in the same way
that Nigel Farage did. So,
you know,
this is not a message
that rich people want you to hear.
So, you know,
we will always get kickback from
billionaire funded think tanks, billionaire owned
newspapers, billionaire owned radio stations.
And that will always be what we fight against.
But what we have, what they don't is that
this is correct and the predictions will be right.
And I'll keep making right predictions
even if they're horrible predictions.
And, you know, that's the way I see it.
And, you know,
I focus on that because that's what I can do.
But I think people watching
who are demanding solutions,
I think they have a choice to make, you know, which is,
number one, do you support
people like me who would do what we're doing?
And number two, do you create your own things?
You know, do you spread the message in your own space?
You know,
whether that means, you know,
creating your own forms of communication
or whether that means spreading amongst your community.
And
the last thing I want to
add on this topic of solutions
is that I think if you've accepted
that it's a long term battle,
then I think the other thing
which is really important is like the...
as much as possible,
how do we maintain our mental health
and our mental health as communities basically?
Because we're going to head into some really,
really, really difficult times
and there's going to be a lot of
like super divisive narratives going around about
and increasingly
young people are going to be forced
to live lives of poverty.
And that is going to be hard.
And I see the damage
it does to the mental health of young people who
are being driven into poverty,
really through no fault of their own,
through a collapsing economy.
And what I want young people to understand is that
the economy is changing in such a way
that poverty is being forced on more and more people.
So I know this is not...
this is easier said than done,
but I think that we
all have to be gentle with ourselves and one another.
And the way that we judge one
another's financial positions,
because we've been kind of trained with this idea
that if you're rich
it’s because you're great
and if you're poor, it's
because you're f*cking dumb or something, you know,
and when you give people that message
in a world that gives people no chance
but to be poor, it's
unbelievably damaging to people’s self-esteem.
And, you know, we're not going to win this fight
with a bunch of people
who have been trained to believe that
they're useless and that their failures,
they're pathetic, you know?
So we need to realise
there's a systemic problem
that is that is f*cking our young people.
And that means that they will be poor
and it's not their fault.
So, you know,
if you're out there and you’re struggle
and you're seeing other people
who are doing better than you,
the truth is probably because of the family
they're from, the family assets that they hold.
Don't beat yourself up on this.
But at the same time, people
need to understand that it's going to be hard
and you're going to have to work hard
in many cases to support yourself,
to support your family.
But just like
I spoke before about
we only win this if we win the technical battle
and the ideological battle,
individual people will only be able
to secure their futures
if they win their personal battles
as well as the political battle.
Because
it doesn't matter how
well I do out here with the politicians, you know,
you need to feed your kids.
So if that means you work hard
and you don’t have time to support
anything we do politically, then that’s you.
I would never judge anyone in that position.
But if you work hard
and do everything you can
to support your kids
but the economy collapses, which it will,
then you know it's going to hit your family as well,
you know.
You know,
sometimes your boat can sink in two ways
and you need to plug a few holes and
I think that...
We will win as a country and as a society
if enough of us are able to
fight both our personal battles
and our collective political battle at the same time.
And I'm well aware that that's much easier for me
who does not have the financial difficulties
that people, other people have.
And for that reason, I will try my best
to take more than my share of the load.
But it will be about whether enough of us can, can
come in and support it.
And, you know, hopefully we'll see this thing grow
and then I'll start to get,
I'll start to get some the politicians
and we can start having more discussions
about the technicalities
of what kind of taxes you bring in.
But now is not the time for that
because we're losing the ideological battle.
And, you know, and,
you know, bad things can happen if we don't win that.
So I'm going to focus on that.
I would like to thank everybody for their support.
You know, I'm sorry to be always coming in
with negative messages,
but I think it's better to know
the truth of what's coming than...
than to be living in a bubble of false hope.
You know, this is what we need to do.
It's going to be hard.
But, you know, tough times create strong people.
And, you know, if we get enough strong people,
then I think we can win.
So, yeah, thanks, everyone, for
thank you, everybody for your support
and keep supporting the channel. Thank you.